Comment je te défonce
Nan nan je crois que tu t'emballes là
Ah nan nan nan moi je pense que je te défonce
attends attends je peux encore revenir-
ET BIM ALLEZ
jte fracasse là !
eh, fatality?
autant y aller franchement
bon bah alors fatality ou quoi ?
Mais ils hésitent !
ben perso moi ça fait trente minutes qu'on se tatane au bout d'un moment j'en ai marre
c'est vrai qu'on se démène
hé, c'est physique !
il n'y a pas que le physique, il y'a le mental aussi ils vont trop loin les mecs
Roooh
Merde !
Ah ! Toi tu vas me cracher du feu sur la gueule
personne crachera du feu sur personne, merde à la fin
c'est bloqué ?
ben non, normalement c'est bas haut haut poing arrière
c'est bizarre
-On pourrait pas faire des fatality plus soft?
-Pour qu'on passe pour ces pédés de street fighter?
non non là tu fais trop de sentiments, regarde, moi la dernière fois j'ai arraché la peau d'un mec... ca ne m'a pas géné
voilà c'est de ça dont on se parle !
On n'enlève pas la peau des gens ! Le type est déjà mort, c'est un problème éthique!
éthique?
c'est de la surenchère du miel sur du sucre
ah...
après ça les gamins n'ont plus de limites
tu sais ce qu'ils devraient faire?
c'est un fatality avec un type qui sodomise l'autre avec un gourdin chauffé à blanc
comme ça, ça lui cautérise l'anus...
WOAH HOHOHO EUH
Tu vois quand je te dis qu'il  faut instaurer des règles !
mais arrête de déconner, c'est génial ! vas-y  fume moi le cul!
Mais t'es un grand malade
Ok on va faire haut bas carré carré croix quart de cercle croix...
C'est quoi ça?
Monsieur Zéro?
oui ?
va falloir être fort vous avez un cancer il vous reste  six mois à vivre...
MORT NATURELLE
Remarquez, scorpion, cancer on a un début d'horoscope hein !